good morning belief nation today's
messages feller was such a phrase over
to you JK Rowling failure meant a
stripping away of the in essential I
stopped pretending to myself that I was
anything other than what I was and began
to direct all my energy into finishing
the only work that mattered to me had I
really succeeded at anything else
I might never have found the
determination to succeed in the one
arena where I believed I truly belonged
I was set free because my greatest fear
had been realized and I was still alive
and I still had a daughter whom I adored
and I had an old typewriter and a big
idea and so rock bottom became the solid
foundation on which I rebuilt my life
you might never fail on the scale I did
but some failure in life is inevitable
it is impossible to live without failing
at something unless you live so
cautiously that you might as well not
have lived at all in which case you fail
by default so I love love love love the
last part of her statement because so
many people are afraid of failing that
they don't even try and that's the
biggest failure of all and I try to use
that as a framework for my life for
everything that I do I don't want to be
afraid of failure I don't want to live
with regret I don't want to look back
and say I wish I had given it more I
wish I gave that a shot man I really
wish that I did something about that I
hate feeling like that and it's easy to
come up with excuses that seem really
logical it's easy to convince yourself
that the reason why you didn't do
something was because you didn't have
enough money you didn't have enough
skills you know your parents didn't
think you'd be able to do it everybody
says you're crazy you know there's all
these reasons that you convinced
yourself why you're not gonna do
something but deep down
if you're honest deep down the reason is
because you're afraid and I hate being
afraid of things so I encourage you to
remember that if you want to do
something great it's gonna come with a
healthy dose of fear fear is normal and
you should feel the fear and do it
anyway so my question today for you
today is what regret are you most afraid
of what we regret do you not want to
have when you look back on your life and
say man I wish that I went after that
what we read don't you want to have
leave in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out and I'm gonna join
in the discussion with you thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events presto